Let us again written to the center. Colorless green ideas sleep furiously. You
and I can quickly recognize, that this sentence is grammatically correct even as
it is semantically meaningless. How do we do it? Consider this mini-grammar.
This is a small subset of the English language grammar consisting of just three
simple rules. The sentence can go into a noun phrase, followed by a verb phrase.
A noun phase can be, optional adjectives, followed by a noun or a pronoun.
The square bracket here means, optional. A verb phrase, composed of a verb,
followed by optional adverb. The variables in this particular sentence,
are the words. The values we assign to them are elliptical categories like verb,
objective, noun and pronoun. If we can make a pastry for
this, that assigned values to this variables in a way that is consistent with
this grammar, then this particular sentence is grammatically correct.
Let's try to make a pastry for this sentence. A sentence can a noun phrase, or
a word phrase. So we may say, that this is a noun phrase and
this is word phrase. Of course at this particular point we do not know,
where we should make this demarcation, what should go into the noun phrase,
what should go into the word phrase? We know whether or
not, this demarcation is correct depending upon whether or not this noun phrase,
and word phrase meet the low level lexical categories. So let's look at
colorless green ideas. We know that a noun phrase can go into one or
more adjectives, followed by a noun or pronoun. So we can look at a lexicon, and
know that ideas are a noun, so we say that this is a noun.
We can look at a lexicon that tells us that colorless and
green are adjectives, and so colorless and green are adjectives here.
We have satisfied this part of the constraint. So I am ready for
the verb phrase, a verb phrase can be composed of a verb, followed by one or
more optional adverbs. We can look in the lexicon, and sleep is a verb, and
furiously is an adverb, so we have satisfied the constraints for
this particular part. Because we have satisfied the constraints,
we know the top level demarcation of this as a noun phrase, and
this as a verb phrase was correct. So the processing is not very top down here.
It also has a bottom up component. In this way we are able to decide,
that this particular sentence is grammatically correct because it satisfies
the constraints of [INAUDIBLE] grammar. Know that we have used knowledge of
constraints, and the matter of constraint propagation, both for
visual processing and for language processing. This sentence method is very
general purpose in doing independent. Once we have done constraint propagation,
to derive the parse tree for the sentence, then we can do additional processing.
We can use this parse tree to support semantic analysis to build
an understanding, a semantic understanding, of the sentence.
Similarly, in visual processing, once we have used the constraints for
doing line labelling. And recognize the surfaces and their orientations.
We can then go on further and recognize the object in its 3D form.